for a game series known for brutal
fighting and gory fatalities
mortal kombat has a surprisingly deep
lore and the new movie adaptation
digs into it so some of the finer points
of the story can get lost in the shuffle
especially if you're not already
familiar with outworld
here's your warning that spoilers are
ahead
mortal kombat is pretty ruthlessly
efficient with its story set up
two dimensions our dimension earth realm
and outworld
are locked in a centuries-long battle
for control occasionally champions for
both sides go head-to-head
in the mortal kombat fighting tournament
the first dimension to win
mortal kombat 10 times gets control of
the other as the movie opens
outworld is leading with nine wins to
earth realm zero
but an ancient prophecy that says a hero
will emerge on earth realm
unites its heroes and turn the tide
since we're coming in on the 10th
tournament
we don't know all the history who set
this whole thing up
why did they decide that a fighting
tournament was the best way to determine
dominance
how did 10 become the magic number where
did the prophecy regarding hanzo
hasashi's descendants come from
and why should we believe it mortal
kombat alludes to some elder gods whose
rules are set
in stone but that's not really an
explanation especially since both sides
break those rules with no real
consequence
maybe the inevitable sequel will dive a
little deeper into these questions
or maybe it's a lot of backstory that
isn't really necessary
if the audience just wants
bone-shattering action
there are apparently two ways to get the
mysterious dragon marks that designate
someone as a mortal combatant
and give them arcana based powers you
can be born with one
or you can earn one by killing someone
with the mark hanzo hasashi's direct
descendant
cole young was born with this he was
born with it
it's not a birthmark cole means you've
been chosen
sonya blade though had to earn her mark
the hard way she got hers by killing
kano
sony explains that jax and kano also got
their marks by force
jax received his after tracking down a
fugitive as part of his military duties
kano killed the target jax and sonia
were tracking once they began
investigating the marks mortal kombat
doesn't clue us in to who these two
people were however
the closest that we get is a newspaper
clipping on sonia's wall as she tells
cole
all about jax's backstory scattered
among the headlines there's something
about the mysterious death
of a famous boxer but there's no
explicit link between the late athlete
and jax
and the clippings position on the board
would indicate that he's more likely a
part of cole's mysterious past
if these people had dragon marks it
stands to reason that they were probably
pretty important but their identities
remain unknown
raiden has been at this whole mortal
combat thing for a long time
he pops up in the movie's prologue
rescuing hanzo hasashi's daughter to
make sure the prophecy is upheld
and he's still fighting centuries later
as shang tsung
decides he's going to preemptively take
out all of earthrealm's champions and
win the latest mortal kombat tournament
before it even begins
raiden's temple has been around for a
while too but it wasn't always so quiet
when liu kang welcomes cole sonia and
kano to the temple
he notes that it was once a place of
worship presumably
raiden once had many followers who
flocked to the holy site
it's not clear what changed to leave it
so desolate and abandoned
there are a few other mysteries
regarding raiden's temple too
like how did kano know where it is sonia
seems to think the temple is very well
hidden but kano implies that people
can't stop talking about it
either sonia and jax are terrible
investigators or kano knows more than
he's letting on
mortal kombat is lousy with alternate
dimensions but the movie only shows us
to a few
earthrealm outworld and netherrealm
which is basically hell
it's only very briefly shown and it
notably shares a name with a development
studio that's been making mortal kombat
games for the past decade or so
but there are other realms too which the
movie doesn't have time to explore
the video games have fleshed out the
franchise's multiverse to an absurd
degree though
in addition to the three realms already
mentioned the games have also introduced
players to adenia
a fairy tale like fantasy world order
realm
where law reigns supreme the anything
goes chaos realm
and heaven which is well heaven it's
never made clear whether the new movie
universe follows the same cosmology
although hints may be lurking in some of
the film's better hidden easter eggs
honestly we wouldn't be surprised to see
adenia make an appearance in a sequel
at least one fan favorite character
katana makes the realm her home
speaking of katana where is she hiding
the writers of mortal kombat deserve
credit for pulling some
pretty deep cuts from the franchise's
expansive roster
but those surprises come at a cost
relatively obscure characters
like natara and reiko get a spotlight
but we never see far better known
characters like jade
kenshi smoke or xiao khan that's
especially true of katana
a mainstay in the games since mortal
kombat 2 given her close ties to molina
who features prominently in mortal
kombat you'd think she'd be in the movie
in the games melina and katana are twins
at least of a sort
for most of her life katana worked as an
outworld assassin
and believed that she and molina were
sisters only later did she discover
the reality of the situation katana is
the princess of adenia
and melina isn't a relative but her evil
clone
in fairness that's a lot of extra story
for a movie that's already packed with
characters
but given molina's fate in mortal kombat
it's a shame that katana didn't get a
chance to share the screen with her
sister
at least once given katana's popularity
and links to the rest of the mortal
kombat cast
her absence is a little baffling the
mortal kombat movie does a pretty good
job of bringing a lot of the game lore
to life on the screen
bihan better known as sub-zero mentions
the lin kuei
a few times scorpion fights for the
shirai ryu
goro shang soon's four-armed minion is
hailed as the prince of the shokan
the movie doesn't have time to explain
what all of these words mean though
so fans of the games may have cheered at
their mention
while others scratched their heads
if the movie is following the game's
story the lin kuei
and the cherie ryu are competing groups
of martial artists
the link way sub-zero's clan hails from
china
at some point a japanese-born ninja
broke off from the group and founded
the sheree ryu leading to a long rivalry
the chokan meanwhile are a race of
half-dragon half-human warriors who
value strength above all
else even the king and queen's children
must fight among themselves to determine
the one true
heir mortal kombat is filled with game
lingo like that
so if you want an explanation for terms
like beau ray cho or references to the
wushi academy
look to the games wisecracking merc
kano an armor-clad warrior cabal have a
history
according to cabal kano is the reason
he's hidden under a hulking metal suit
want to know more too bad mortal kombat
establishes that the two characters have
a fractious relationship
but the specifics remain a mystery
clearly
kano and cabal's falling out has
something to do with the black dragon
which according to the game's story
is a criminal cabal made up of
mercenaries kano is its leader
cabal was one of the group's members and
jax was the special forces operative
tasked with bringing the whole thing
down
a big difference between the games and
the movie in fact is that in the games
jax not reptile is responsible for
kano's facial scars
the movie seems like it switched a few
other things up a little it sure doesn't
sound like kano's in charge of the black
dragon anymore
and we don't know why he and cabal
fought what happened to the black dragon
or what specifically cabal offered him
to switch sides
this is something that could get more
attention in a later mortal combat movie
but given the way that both characters
ended up it seems like this story thread
may just be left dangling
mortal kombat manages to squeeze every
character from the first game
except johnny cage who's clearly been
saved for the next installment
and most from the second into the movie
and it adds a bunch more characters from
later entries in the series
it also manages to kill a ton of them
off kano reptile
goro molina kung lao and sub-zero
all die in brutal bloody fashion making
their appearance in any sequels
pretty unlikely or is it these are some
of the most iconic characters in the
entire franchise
and it's hard to imagine a mortal combat
movie without them
sub-zero will be easy to replace without
deviating too far
from established cannon in the games the
sub-zero mantle is taken up by b
han's younger brother huay liang but the
movie introduces a loophole for everyone
else too
after all hanzo hasashi dies in the
pre-credit sequence
only to return at the film's climax
stronger than ever
who's to say the rest of the combatants
can't do the same
the movie mortal kombat might have ended
before the mortal kombat tournament
even really got underway shang tsung's
evil scheme after all
is to hunt down and take out
earthrealm's forces before the
tournament begins
leaving his side with a victory by
default
kill them ultimately cole young rallies
the good guys and decides to fight
sung's warriors on his own terms
but other than a throwaway line about
bringing the tournament to them
there's no indication that mortal kombat
ever started
the movie implies quite the opposite
when young and the rest
first arrive at raiden's temple liu kang
hints that the tournament is about a
month away
and it sure doesn't seem like anyone
spends more than a few days training
but when the movie ends it's also
heavily implied earthrealm has won
that means one of a few things have
happened one
maybe the movie's sense of time is just
skewed and the one-on-one battles that
make up the film's climax comprise the
actual tournament
two with outworld's forces decimated the
tournament has been postponed or
cancelled
three the tournament is still going to
happen at the designated date
and we just haven't gotten there yet
that last option seems absurd
but it also explains why young wants to
get to hollywood to recruit johnny cage
as quickly as possible
mortal kombat fatalities are a piece of
video game history
the gruesome finishing moves were so
controversial
that they were one of the catalysts for
the video game industry creating the
entertainment software rating board
the organization that slaps movie-like
content ratings on games
midway the company that originally
developed and published mortal kombat
didn't respond by cutting out fatalities
though
instead it stuffed later mortal kombat
titles full of alternative finishing
moves
some of which poked fun at the scandal
in an animality
a player's character transforms into a
beast then proceeds to maul their
opponent
a friendship is like an anti-fatality
ending the match with a peaceful gesture
like blowing bubbles or giving an
opponent a birthday cake
fatalities are reserved for players who
disconnect during online matches
while hari kiri's let defeated players
off themselves
the most memorable though are babalities
which turn rival fighters
into infants sadly while mortal kombat
is full of classic fatalities
remember when kano rips out reptile's
heart yeah you've seen that before
the movie is entirely babality free at
least we do see
a few friendships blossom check out one
of our news videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]